la frc a le département de la réunion le
syndicat du sucre de la réunion nous
présente terre d'ici
pour
installé à saint pierre sandrine beau
cultive de la tomate sous abri soucieuse
de produire des fruits de qualité
irréprochable sandrine tests
régulièrement de nouvelles variétés afin
de trouver la tomate idéal on fait de la
tomate grappe depuis trois ans bientôt
quatre ans mais tous les ans on essaie
de nouvelles variétés alors seulement
sur d'oran pour pas prendre de gros
risques au niveau de la production
mais pour améliorer la qualité les
tomates grappes
on essaie tout et tous les ans on essaie
au moins deux variétés pour diversifier
pour trouver un produit qui correspond
bien au climat qui correspond bien aux
pressions phytosanitaires et qui est du
goût toujours plus de goût quoi qu'ils
soient toujours qui est toujours plus de
qualité gustative
toujours à la recherche de l'excellence
sandrine a planté pour la première fois
un rang de coeur de boeuf la reine des
tomates un privilège coeur de boeuf
coeur de boeuf en et c'est toujours le
steak de la tomate
on peut considérer pour moi c'est une
des meilleures tomates de bouche assez
ça avec un filet d'huile une feuille de
basilic un peu de fleur de sel et en au
paradis ça me plaît bien aussi souvent
il ya des essais donc on trouve des
variétés qui sont résistantes donc là il
ya des firmes qui nous proposent des
variétés résistantes maintenant c'est à
nous de d'avoir les critères sur le goût
de la tomate adhérents de la coopérative
vivait à sandrine fournit bien sûr une
partie des belles tomates qui
composeront les paniers fraîcheurs
commercialisé par sa coopérative un
assortiment de légumes frais vendus
directement du producteur au
consommateur la satisfaction que j'ai
c'est que je récolte le matin et dans la
journée c'est dans les paniers
donc je sais que le produit
est ce un au départ et ni sain et frais
dans le panier dans la journée même car
pour produire ces tomates de qualité
sandrine n'utilise pas de pesticides
elle fait appel à des auxiliaires de
culture des micro guêpe utile pour
lutter contre les ravageurs avant
récolte je peux éventuellement utiliser
un produit chimique mais à partir du
moment où les fruits arrivent à maturité
et à récolte je sais ce que je disais
rue 10 récolte trois fois par semaine et
je peux utiliser aucun produit chimique
donc je vais je privilégie les luttes
alternatives dont les introductions
d'insectes pour les aleurodes et je
travaille sur du cycle court
c'est encourageant d'autant plus que ça
me permets moi à travers les paniers de
de mettre à disposition de mes clients
des produits qui voilà qui soit d'un
point de vue gustatif très intéressant
au niveau de la production aussi c'est
respectueux de l'environnement puisque
une utilisation de produits
phytosanitaires qui est quand même
vraiment diminué voire inexistante pour
certains de certaines productions sa
viande est récoltée s'est tout de suite
envoyé chez mes clients dont il ya eu
une bonne relation entre les producteurs
et les consommateurs jouent bien
des fruits et légumes bien frais livrés
directement sur le lieu de travail
c'est le concept du panier fraîcheur que
propose la coopérative vivait à ce sa
ligne de conditionnement
guillaume grondin chef de compléter les
caissettes de légumes de la prochaine
commande
en fait on termine avec les oignons
l'ail et le teint après comme ça les
paniers sont prévues devrait on les
charge dans le camion
comme ces fonds à température ambiante
et le lendemain ils sont frais prêts à
consommer sur des lignes de 28 paniers
sur des lignes de préparation 28 paniers
ceci étant effectivement avec
l'extension de la coopérative on va
pouvoir bénéficier d'une zone de
préparation de 90 mètres carrés ce qui
n'a concrètement plus grand chose à voir
avec cette zone actuelle ce qui nous
permettra aussi de pouvoir travailler
sur la certification sur laquelle on
travaille actuellement à savoir le pea
nana son entreprise c'est donc le plan
national nutrition en entreprise à
destination des salariés qui consistera
principalement sur une mise à
disposition en gratuité pour les
salariés de corbeille à fruits
voilà ce qui permettra d'augmenter
l'accessibilité en produits frais en
entreprise et aussi de pouvoir relancer
la consommation de 5 fruits par jour ou
portions en attendant la fraîcheur des
produits est garantie par la qualité des
fruits et légumes qui sont livrés dès le
lendemain de leur récolte un service
express qui séduit de nombreux clients
oui voilà c'est certaines personnes
n'ont pas attendre que leur marché et
être veut que les produits sont peu
chères
ou non parce qu'on nous propose c'est de
livres étaient là tout le monde
travaille comme ça les gens quand ils
rentrent chez eux il reste juste à
cuisiner
et à consommer
oui ca c'est clairement un gain de temps
qui est qui est pas négligeable pour les
clients pagny effectivement puisque la
plupart des clients sont des gens qui
ont des plannings d'activités je dirais
qu'ils sont extrêmement chargé et
effectivement avoir la capacité la
possibilité d'avoir accès à des produits
qui soient effectivement issu d'une
production respectueuse et c'est de
l'environnement avec des produits qui
sont ultra frais voilà c'est un service
qui est confortable pour eux je dirais
voilà là on a réussi juste à 50 mètres
attention ce top et puis entre une place
pour se garer et puis on va aller voter
au volant de son fourgon guillaume
sillonnent ainsi toutes les semaines les
quatre coins de l'île pour livrer ses
paniers pleins de vitamines
bonjour sûr que vos livraison des
paniers fraîcheur après câble il ya deux
panneaux spéciaux
oui c'était sans oignon s'en aille sans
tain remplacé par brocoli avec un v6
vous conseille de consommer brocoli
rapidement parce que là ça tiendra pas
une semaine la recette de rugby avec ses
impeccables avec l'avantagé d'avoir des
légumes nouveau et ça me donne envie de
faire de la cuisine différemment c'est
ça qui est bien c'est que chaque semaine
j'aménage avec les recettes de qui ne
sont donnés sur le sur le net un petit
peu plus haut déjà ça nous fait
découvrir des produits qu'on connaissait
enfin qu'on achèterait pas forcément et
apprendre à la recette qui va avec donc
ça permet d'avoir des nouvelles saveurs
et de savoir les cuisines etc aura donc
c'est bien
temps
pour